was sie hier sieht sind historische
aufnahmen vom 17 dezember 1903 an diesem
tag starteten die gebrüder wright den
ersten motorisierten flug der welt und
landeten ihn auch wieder erfolgreich
und auch wenn dieser erste flugversuche
nicht viel mehr als ein weiter sprung
war läutete er doch das zeitalter der
motorisierten luftfahrt ein
aus unserem heutigen leben ist das
fliegen nicht mehr wegzudenken
das hat unsere welt näher
zusammengebracht und ständig arbeiten
wir daran die technologie
weiterzuentwickeln
jetzt stehen wir kurz davor einen neuen
durchbruch zu erzielen einen durchbruch
der mindestens genauso schwierig wird
wie der flug von den gebrüdern wright am
30 juli 2020 startete eine der
bedeutendsten mars missionen bisher eine
atlas 5 541 trägerrakete ist gerade
dabei den rover province zum mars zu
bringen
der soll dort gesteinsproben entnehmen
und nach leben auf dem mars ausschau
halten
doch er ist nicht alleine unterwegs denn
unten am ufer befestigt ist ingenieure
der erste maß helikopter genau wie die
gebrüder wright vor knapp 120 jahren
möchte die nasa den ersten motorisierten
flug der menschheitsgeschichte
durchführen
nur auf einem anderen planeten warum das
war eine enorm schwierige aufgabe ist
und was sich die nasa davon erhofft das
erfahrt ihr heute nach dem intro
[Musik]
der rover prinz ist der bisher größte
und fortschrittlichste rover der nasa
das muss er aber auch sein denn er soll
die frage klären ob es leben auf dem
mars gibt oder zumindest mal gegeben hat
darüber hinaus möchte man mit hilfe
seiner daten auch einen geeigneten ort
für eine basis auf dem roten planeten
finden
mit an bord hat der rover verschiedenste
technologien die die nasa erst testen
muss bevor sie von menschen auf dem mars
eingesetzt werden können mit einem gerät
soll zum beispiel sauerstoff aus der
marianischen atmosphäre extrahiert
werden das wäre eine möglichkeit
zukünftige maß astronauten mit
sauerstoff zu versorgen
allerdings hat die marsatmosphäre nur
eine dichte von weniger als einem
prozent im vergleich zu der atmosphäre
ich hier auf der erde
was das ganze ziemlich schwierig macht
darüber hinaus soll per se wir uns mit
einem bohrer gesteinsproben entnehmen
diese legt er dann in einem speziellen
behälter in seinem inneren ab so dass
sie auf einer späteren mission wieder
eingesammelt werden können
der rover ist zusätzlich auch mit
hochauflösenden kameras ausgestattet
insgesamt hat die nasa 7 hoch
entwickelte systeme in ihm verbaut
mit hilfe dieser instrumente soll per se
wir uns dann auch nach einem geeigneten
landeplatz für zukünftige bemannte
missionen suchen
doch die wohl größte herausforderung
besteht wahrscheinlich darin ingenieure
den ersten mass helikopter auf dem mars
fliegen zu lassen
ingenuity ist wohl das komplizierteste
gerät an bord von rover übersetzt
bedeutet der name einfallsreichtum und
davon braucht die nasa beim design des
fluggeräts wahrscheinlich eine ganze
menge
ingenuity soll sich nämlich
selbstständig von rover lösen sich
ausrichten und dann autonom abheben
können natürlich nur von den stellen die
durch die daten von prinz als sinnvoll
erachtet wurden
sometimes you have to do is something
drastisch hofert grip der gp pilot von
nassau skeptischen laboratorien sagte
zur mission folgendes als die gebrüder
wright das erste mal flogen saßen sie in
einem experimentellen fluggerät und auf
genau dieselbe art und weise wurde der
mast helikopter design
er soll zeigen dass wir einen
motorisierten helikopter in der
marianischen atmosphäre fliegen lassen
können ähnlich wie overath und sein
bruder wilbur auf der erde muss die nasa
die speziellen gegebenheiten des mars in
ihre berechnungen mit einbeziehen denn
die könnten nicht unterschiedlicher sein
ich hatte ja schon erwähnt dass die
atmosphäre auf dem mars wesentlich
dünner ist als die auf der erde
ingenuity besteht aus ganz leichten
materialien wie zum beispiel kohlefaser
deshalb wiegt der helikopter auf der
erde auch nur 1,8 kilogramm
obwohl er einen halben meter groß ist
die rotorblätter sind dazu auch noch
deutlich größer und drehen sich viel
schneller als es auf der erde nötig wäre
denn auf dem mars braucht er deutlich
mehr auftriebskraft um überhaupt abheben
zu können
[Musik]
also halten wir mal fest die erste
herausforderung für das fliegen ist die
atmosphäre stimmen die berechnungen der
nasa dann sollte das fliegen jedoch
technisch möglich sein
das wurde auch schon unter künstlicher
gestellten bedingungen getestet
ingenuity soll sich mit hilfe von
solarzellen bei tag wieder aufladen
bei nacht steht man dann allerdings vor
der nächsten herausforderung der kälte
nachts wird es auf dem mars bis zu minus
90 grad celsius kalt nicht alle bauteile
halten solchen bedingungen auf lange
zeit stand deshalb werden zwei drittel
der energie nur dafür benutzt die
technik warm zu halten
tests hier auf der erde deuteten zwar
darauf hin dass die komponenten diesen
temperaturen standhalten müssten
der helikopter wird aber hier bis an
seine grenzen strapaziert daher sieht
die nasa das reine überleben von den
schnitt schon als teilerfolg an
ich sag's dir doch mal ganz klar so
etwas wurde bisher noch nie versucht die
nasa steht hier wirklich vor einer
monumentalen aufgabe
deshalb hofft das ingenieurteam zwar auf
einen erfolg rechnet aber schon mit
rückschlägen
stellt euch vor ihr wollt eine drohne
fliegen nur steht die auf einem anderen
planeten der 225 millionen kilometer
entfernt ist denn als letzte große
herausforderung gilt die kommunikation
die nasa kann aufgrund der entfernung
zum mars den helikopter nicht direkt
kontrollieren da die verzögerung einfach
viel zu groß wäre dies ein signal auf
dem roten planeten ankommt kann es 20
minuten dauern
es gibt daher nur ein strafbefehl und
ingenuity muss dann autonom abheben und
fliegen die nasa muss also dann dem
ersten motorisierten flug der menschheit
auf einem anderen planeten
ohne menschen durchführen dafür nutzt
der helikopter eine reihe von geräten um
die entfernung zum boden oder anderen
objekten zu bestimmen und seinen kurs
anzupassen wenn es nötig sein sollte das
signal für den staat wird von der erde
an einen satelliten im mars orbit dann
an providence und schlussendlich zu
ingenuity geschickt wenn diese
signalkette erfolgreich funktioniert und
das signal beim fluggerät ankommt sieht
die nasa das ebenfalls schon als
teilerfolg an
auch wenn der flug selbst ist dann
später nicht ist gehen wir also mal
davon aus dass presseevents in sechs
monaten mit samt im schnitt erfolgreich
auf dem mars landet ingenuity löst sich
sicher von rover und es funktionstüchtig
der helikopter überlebt die eiskalte
nächte von minus 90 grad schafft es sich
selbst mit energie zu versorgen
hält den befehl zum start und schaffte
es von selbst abzuheben und wieder zu
landen
was bringt uns all das dann naja zum
einen wäre uns menschen der erste
motorisierte flug auf einem anderen
planeten gelungen insbesondere auf dem
mars den wir in den nächsten jahrzehnten
kolonisieren wollen
ein erster schritt für weitere fluggerät
auf dem mars wäre ebenfalls getan und
man hätte echte daten mit denen man
solche fluggeräte erforschen könnte
zum anderen können wir eine weitere
dimension des planeten nutzen um in
zukunft objekte zu transportieren
zum beispiel während des baus einer mars
basis und selbst wenn das noch
zukunftsmusik ist hat ancelotti auch
einen direkten nutzen der helikopter
gibt uns eine neue perspektive und
kannte erreichen wo ein rover bisher
nicht hin konnte in der zukunft könnten
wir solche helikopter vor schicken um
eine umgebung auszukundschaften bevor
wir oder ein rowa sich auf den weg
dorthin machen
voll aufgeladen reicht die energie von
ingenuity für einen 90 sekündigen flug
insgesamt sind fünf flugversuche geplant
ob der helikopter seine mission
erfolgreich durchführen kann das wissen
wir ab dem 18 februar 2021 denn dann
landet presseevents voraussichtlich auf
dem mars und falls ihr das nicht
verpassen wollt folgten es gerne auf
instagram doktor watson da posten mir
sowieso jeden tag eine spannende science
news und wir werden euch garantiert auf
dem laufenden halten was provence und
ingenuity auf dem weg zum mars und dann
später nach der mars landung alles zu
machen werden ansonsten wir uns einen
personal replicator dabei helfen kann
eine maß basis zu bauen das erfahrt ihr
hier
und ob wir bald alle auf dem mars leben
werden das erfahrt ihr hier unten ein
etwas älteres video aber immer noch
ziemlich spannend ansonsten vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
patrick